Two private spacecraft are on their way to the moon to carry out separate missions.
The landers launched January 15 from the American government's Kennedy Space Center in Florida.
The private company SpaceX used its Falcon 9 launch vehicle to fly the landers into space.
The two separated from Falcon 9 about one hour into the flight.
Mission leaders said the launch went exactly as planned with no problems reported.
The trip to the moon will take some time.
One spacecraft is expected to land on the lunar surface in early March,
while the other should touch down in late May or early June.
In February 2024, the first private spacecraft completed the first US moon landing in more than
50 years. The lander, called Odysseus, was developed by the Texas-based company Intuitive Machines.
The spacecraft experienced some technical problems, but was able to carry out several science
experiments before powering down permanently on the moon in late March.
For this current mission, Texas-based Firefly Aerospace developed Blue Ghost, one of the two
landers launched. The other, named Resilience, belongs to Japanese company Ice Space.
Both are designed to collect data and materials to support several planned moon missions,
some including astronauts in coming years. The Blue Ghost lander is targeting a landing site
near a volcanic structure called Mons-La Trée. It is a 480 km basin that sits in the northeast
quarter of the near side of the moon. The American Space Agency, NASA, says the two-meter tall Blue
Ghost, is carrying ten NASA science and technology instruments. They aim to gather valuable scientific
data studying Earth's nearest neighbor. The agency said, NASA's Artemis program aims to send
astronauts to the moon for the first time since the Apollo 17 mission in 1972.
The next planned flight in that program is Artemis II, which is set to launch in April 2026.
In that mission, four astronauts will fly NASA's Orion spacecraft more than 400,000 kilometers
on a trip around the moon. Nikola Fox is the Associate Administrator for NASA's Science Mission
Directorate in Washington, DC. She said in a statement, the agency's cooperation with private
companies is a critical part of bringing humanity back to the moon. Fox added that NASA
chose the new experiments partly because of information learned from NASA's Apollo Space Program,
which began in the 1960s. She said the current mission seeks to ensure the safety and health
of our future science instruments, spacecraft, and most importantly, our astronauts on the lunar
surface. Blue Ghost's equipment includes a tool to collect dirt and another to dig a hole
for measuring temperatures below the lunar surface. The spacecraft is also carrying a device built
to measure light reflections to be used with lasers to better measure the distance between Earth
and the moon. In addition, Blue Ghost is carrying instruments to examine the structure and density
of areas beneath the lunar surface.
equipment will seek to capture X-ray images of the edge of Earth's magnetic field.
The ice-space lander resilience is carrying an exploring vehicle called a rover to the
moon.
The 5-kilogram rover is designed to collect lunar soil and other materials from the surface.
Resilience is also carrying equipment and instruments to complete several experiments for
Japanese companies and other organizations.
One of the experiments will test an electrolysis device designed to separate water into hydrogen
and oxygen.
Such a device could help future astronauts better use water resources on the moon and
produce rocket fuel.
Other experiments set for the resilience mission include food production tests and the deployment
of a deep-space radiation probe.
The instrument is designed to collect detailed measurements of ionizing radiation in space.
NASA has said it is paying $101 million to Firefly for the mission and another $44 million
for the experiments.
Officials from ice-space did not report how much its mission would cost.
It is the second moon mission for ice-space.
During the last one, Japan's Space Agency, Jaxa, successfully launched its slim spacecraft
to the moon in January 2024.
But the lander touched down imperfectly, causing some communication and power problems.
However, Japanese space officials reported they had stayed in communication with slim through
late April.
During this time they said the spacecraft was able to collect valuable data about the landing
and surrounding area.
I'm Brian Lynn.